[Music]
far beneath the palace of the
treacherous king - and the damp darkness
of an inescapable labyrinth a horrific
beast stalks the endless corridors of
its prison enraged with bloodlust
so intense and his deafening roar shakes
the earth it is easy to see why the
Minotaur myth has a long history of
being disregarded as pure fiction
however there's a good chance at the
Minotaur and other monsters and gods
were created by our early ancestors to
rationalize the terrifying things that
they saw in the natural world but did
not understand and while we can't
explain every aspect of their stories
there may be some actual science that
reveals itself when we dissect them for
clues so as far as we know that have
never been human bull hybrids but the
earliest material written about the
Minotaur doesn't even mention its
physical form so that's probably not the
key part of the story what the different
tellings do agree upon however is that
the Beast lives underground and when it
bellows it causes tremendous problems
the various myths are also specific in
stating that genius inventor Daedalus
carved out the labyrinth beneath the
island of Crete archaeological attempts
to find the fabled maze have come up
empty-handed but treat itself has
yielded the most valuable clue of all in
the form of seismic activity Crete sits
on a piece of continental crust called
the Aegean block and has a bit of
oceanic crust known as the nubian block
sliding right beneath it this sort of
geologic feature called a subduction
zone is common all over the world and
results in lots of earthquakes
however in Crete the situation is
particularly volatile as a nubian block
is attached to the massive buoyant
continental crust that is Africa when
the nubian block moves it does not go
down nearly as easily or as steeply as
oceanic crust does in most other
subduction zones instead it violently
and abruptly forces sections of the
Mediterranean upwards in an event called
uplift and Crete is an uplift central in
the year 2014
Crete had more than 1300 earthquakes of
magnitude 2.0 or higher by comparison in
the same period of time Southern
California a much larger area
experienced a mere 255 earthquakes of
course we don't have detailed seismic
records from the days of King Minos but
we do know from fossil records and
geologic evidence that create has
experienced serious uplift events that
sometimes exceeded 30 feet in a single
moment contrast this for a moment with
the island of hawaii where earthquakes
and volcanic activity were tightly woven
to legends surrounding Pele a goddess
with fiery and fair like the Minotaur
her myths included tales of destruction
but they also contained elements of
dance and creation so why did Hawaii end
up with Pele and create end up with the
Minotaur the difference likely comes
down to the lava that followed many of
Hawaii's worst earthquakes the lava on
Hawaii is made of basalt which once
cooled is highly fertile within a couple
of decades of terrible eruptions
Islanders would have seen a vibrant
green life thriving on new peninsulas
made of lava so it makes sense that the
mythology captured this by portraying
Pele as a creator as well as a destroyer
as for the people of Crete their
earthquakes brought only destruction and
barren lands so perhaps for them the
unnatural in deadly Minotaur was born
the connections between mythical stories
and the geology of the regions were they
originated teach us that mythology and
science are actually two sides of the
same coin both are rooted in explaining
and understanding the world the key
difference is that we're mythology uses
gods monsters and magic science uses
measurements records and experiments
[Applause]
[Music]